entrepreneurship is not predicated on  taking away from your family  entrepreneurship is from taking away  from everything else so stop making  excuses  oh these millennial kids are so entitled  these kids didn't have to work as hard  as we did nobody cares if you're 40 70  90 alien female male minority the market  will accept your victories if you're  good enough to have a victory and I  believe more than ever that if you're a  49 year old housewife with two kids  because of this phone you've got more  opportunities to create something for  yourselves please my friends do not  allow just the 18 and 14 and 22 year  olds to grab at this pie that is so  available to all of us regardless of our  age we're gonna live longer the  opportunity is real for the 58 year old  right now that's watching us it'll live  another 40 years 40 years of being able  to do something you love is a big deal  start putting in the work start  recognizing this isn't just a young  person's game